hey you're here to see Bill Elliott
going back come on in lots of people
like to come to this office and look at
some of the things that have been
collected over the years my wife and are
originally from Massachusetts we came
came to pencil Pittsburgh we have no
family in this part of the world getting
out trying to understand a little bit
about western Pennsylvania we started to
attend a variety of flea markets
everyone said why would see a pennant or
a football program or something about
Carnegie Tech ebay just redefined the
whole issue with regard to a marketplace
and a customer and obviously the ebay
does have the opportunity just as in a
live auction you can bit up but at the
same time obviously there's a time frame
I've lost items because I've been it's a
meeting and obviously the auction closes
out but that's the fun of the that's the
fun of the chase so I've collected it
and put it in this office to the point
that rather than put it in the archives
I think it's very important for young
people as well as prospective students
and alums that will come back just to
look at and remember gee this is what I
remember when I was a student here we
tell you that is that the oldest item in
this office is in fact this up lapel pin
which in fact is from 1907 when in fact
it was the Carnegie technical schools
some of the things that's been lots of
fun is to think about the classic
statement which I asked lots of people
that is that what are the new ways to do
old jobs go back in the history this
institution 1970 was about sixty-five
percent of the students were from
Pennsylvania we talked about a variety
of ways through to kind of just change
the way we did business just think about
today if you would on a high school
visit and talk with a group of students
for 15 or 20 minutes you think you could
explain all there is to know about
Carnegie Mellon in 15 or 20 minutes so
that was a that was a problem try to
give a student an idea of a sample in a
sample of education is very difficult to
convey and the real issue was to bring
students on campus not really what gave
way to the sleeping bag weekend that's
been the fun of this
this is to watch the business change
over the last 40 some-odd years and
obviously in that case March Carnegie
Mellon change and I started in nineteen
nineteen seventy putting materials on
the back of the door which is when I
occupied the office as a director of
admission on the first floor of this
building it's a bit sentimental and I
could quickly point out to you some of
the folks that here's a picture of dick
sired was obviously no longer with us so
it's a picture of Aughrim madani who for
many years was the Dean of the College
of Fine Arts I see down here at the
bottom longtime picture of one of the
first admits that I did at Carnegie
Mellon way down here in the bottom when
he had a mustache is a picture of
Michael sty tell Michael style is
currently the director of admission
young man that I have been into Carnegie
Mellon when he came from deriv high
school in allentown pennsylvania in 1974
and some of you probably know the story
he was a work-study student in the
admission office when i was the director
of admission he then became the
associate director admission and the
director of admission I think it Mike
would say that I'm the only person he's
worked for since he was 17 years old and
we're still friends that's the important
part this piece right here on the coffee
table is from the fence and many years
ago the fence was starting to
deteriorate and Dean Murphy and I he
went through a process of replacing some
of the cross members and in fact I cut
off a section of the fence and you can
see the multiple layers of paint the
many pets that we have I they said were
collected through ebay I do think that
the oldest penet is this one this one is
around 1909 I believe was given to me by
a widow whose husband had been a
Carnegie Tech graduate the other items
and that is that there is a jacket over
here from Earl swank Swank for many
years was the Dean of Student Affairs
and as I understand the story students
had this jacket made for Earl flank it
was a quite portly gentleman to put this
on it is a
kind of a striking jacket you can
certainly walk across campus and attract
attention if you were to wear this
jacket out among the students the tech
beer is an interesting story tech beer
is was brewed by the Pittsburgh Brewing
Company some of the very early bottles
or this one here with the bonny lass on
it so these are some of the early early
beer cans and pear bottles and the most
recent where they stop growing tech beer
or these small ones that are over here
in the back written with green pens
since 1970 surprised there isn't one of
my shirt pocket you can see on my desk
and lots of other things the green pen
is me and the use of the green pen can
be important with those of us that are
in the admission business because when
you read through folders and markup
folders you had absolute assurance that
you were the one that actually read the
folder if in fact in my case it was
written with green ink so even though
I'm getting ready to retire I did in
fact only within the last couple of
weeks find this booklet done by you can
see very Slocum being who was kinda tech
41 she was from California and did a
wide variety of sketches about what
Carney who was like as they say i'm not
i'm not a carnegie graduate nor am i
from the city of Pittsburgh so it's been
lots of fun to learn about the
University in the 37 38 years I've been
here as well as the city of Pittsburgh
if there's other questions that you have
about the campus or about my office I'll
be more than happy to help you